Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill bar and it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Monday morning podcast.
Just before Friday.
Yeah.
I'm just checking in on you,
man.
How's your week going?
Is it flying by?
Hopefully we've got to make something that summer's almost going away.
Um,
I absolutely butchered.
So fucking chicken on the big green egg.
How the fuck do you do that?
I'll tell you how you do that.
You'll walk away from it,
right?
And you'll run into you a little later.
You know when she's going through some emotional shit and you gotta be there
for,
are you blaming your wife built?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I was already going to fuck it up because I didn't,
you know,
I never cooked chicken on that thing and they will like really thin too.
And uh,
I,
I dunno,
I don't know what the fuck I did,
but it tastes like fucking shoe leather.
Tough like fucking shoe leather.
That forking chicken was terrible,
but I ate it anyways.
German Irish plowed,
right fucking throw it.
You would've thought I was eating a fucking lamb shank.
Is the lamb shank good?
The fuck is going on with my ac.
We go
at the fucking thing closed there.
Um,
anyways,
by the way,
I got a lot of,
a lot of letters,
a lot of tweaks,
a lot of twitters all wrapped up in the court here.
Um,
about last week's podcast,
Monday mornings pot,
uh,
Monday morning podcast.
It got cut off in the end for whatever reason.
Um,
I still have the audio.
So in classic radio,
old school radio,
I'm going to give you a teaser.
Hey,
off the top,
he ended the podcast.
Who going to have the lost footage from our fucking apple slaw for while Mama,
I'm going to play it at the end.
All right,
that's my little teaser.
Like you can't just fast forward to the fucking end and listen to my answer.
Um,
you know,
stay k folks,
stick around.
Don't forget to stick around to the end of the podcast.
Don't forget to not hit the fast forward button and stick around.
Stick around coming up with a top of the hour.
We've got that red headed Khan to ask him that question that got cut off from
four days ago.
Um,
anyway,
so it's Thursday,
Huh?
It's today payday for you.
The fuck did they take from you?
Now you have to think about that.
How much money they take out of taxes and the amount that actually goes towards
this shit that they need to fix.
What do you think it is?
You know what I mean?
They take a nice fucking sweet fucking 30,
35% of all your,
God.
Damn.
I was probably more than that.
I'm just talking about idea.
Check with,
forget about that.
The hidden gas tax,
right?
Every time you go out to get a a,
one of them little medicine things for the fucking corn on your foot,
you know,
there's tax on that.
This fucking tax on everything.
It was pissing me off the other day.
I was thinking about how when cars first came out,
you just had a fucking car and you drove around.
It was all good.
Then they had to regulate them and you to get a license plates they knew who
have fuck everybody was and next thing you need to pay taxes on it.
The fuck am I giving you money for?
You know,
oh,
for the roads,
man,
for the fucking roads.
Fuck you.
You can build a road for like fucking 700 bucks.
I swear to God with you,
if you really cut through all the bullshit,
you know,
like right now I'm having this,
this little closet thing made on the outside of my house.
I already had this little closet thing,
but it was,
you know,
it was a dirt floor and that type of shit.
So I'm having put a little concrete on the floor,
give me a little door,
put some shelves in there and I can get some of the shit out of my garage.
Right.
So the guy goes out.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
My friend,
anytime anybody says my friend,
then they can teach.
They're not going to treat you like a friend and a guy came back with this
astronomical fucking thing and I was just like,
really?
Come on buddy.
No,
no,
no.
The fucking concrete that's going to cost like 10 grand and a,
the screwdrivers are like 500 bucks a piece plus Labor.
It's just like,
how do you do that all day?
How do you do?
How do you just fucking walk around?
They just look at you and they guy,
right?
What can I take this dope for?
Let's check 'em out.
Lack of pigment.
Couple of freckles.
Ah,
man.
He had fucking orange hair when he was a kid.
Oh,
this guy's got no self esteem.
I'm going high on this one.
You know what I mean?
Bye.
Came out,
came out looking like,
what's his face if fucking dude in archer,
right.
Jet Black hair with the fucking steel blue eyes.
I probably got the whole thing done for 300 bucks.
Um,
you know what's funny?
I'm at the age,
I don't even give a fuck.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
That makes you feel good.
That's going to fill up the fucking back of your jeans so I don't have to look
at your ass crack.
Go ahead.
Go ahead and do it.
Go ahead and knock it out there buddy.
And uh,
I'll get all the shit out of my garage and I'll just go jump on a stage and
dance like a fucking monkey and that'll pay for the closet.
How about that?
How about that,
sir?
How about that?
Alright.
You could sit there with your little Igloo.
Fucking hey.
You know my wife gave me shit because I called alligator shirts,
Lacoste shirts.
I call them izods went,
they called izods back in the day.
You know,
this is one of the things as you,
as you fucking get older as is,
the names of shit changes.
And if you,
if you're not real careful,
it'll make you feel like you're going senile.
KFC,
it's Kentucky Fried Chicken.
Look cost.
It's an alligator shirt and izod don't get a fucking guy dude.
I fucking,
I had a scratch cat do it.
I got to fucking like 10 izods going to show up to score.
You'll see me two weeks straight.
Never see the same shirt twice.
Um,
so anyway,
so that things get done and all of that shit.
Um,
AH,
Christ,
I got nothing to talk about.
My life's been just going fucking great.
It might,
let's go on.
So great.
I'm not even,
I'm not even afraid to say that.
You don't really think it is.
Instead of,
I've just been in that goddamn editing,
editing this cartoon,
and it keeps getting funnier and I can't wait for it to come up.
So let's talk about the,
the,
the little amount of shit that I've paid attention to,
sort of paying attention to the election this year,
simply because there's a bush in a Clinton and it again and I,
and I liking that Jeb Bush doesn't seem like he's getting anywhere.
I can't believe Hillary Clinton.
Yeah.
People.
How many fucking times do you got to get fucked over by that last name,
Bush or Clinton before you just want somebody new fucking you over.
Is it the familiarity?
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
it did.
And they are pushing her so fucking hard on CNN.
Just completely ignoring that.
She had a bunch of top secret documents on our laptop.
She's a complete piece of shit.
Just like a debt,
not a dad.
Sorry.
You're fucking sugar daddy.
What did we call him?
I her fucking living arrangement.
Her husband.
Right.
Okay.
She goes to those fucking Bilderberg meetings.
She's in the Goddamn Illuminati.
What the fuck are you?
Why would you want her in there?
I've always been a Yankee fan.
You remember that when she lied about that with a brand new Yankee hat,
they want four fucking championships while her husband was in office.
She never said boo about it and all of a sudden she wants to run for fucking
office in New York Gang.
[inaudible] oh my God.
And all the fucking women's groups,
they don't give a fuck.
As long as it's got a clam,
they don't give a shit.
If it's the spawn of Satan,
they're gonna fucking vote for it.
And you know what?
Go ahead and do it.
You're going to get what you deserve.
Okay,
so fucking done.
The dumbest thing guys ever did was shut women out of stuff.
So now they just fucking vote for shit.
Just cause it's a woman.
It's stupid.
We'll get and what the fuck we deserve?
Why do they got to be a part of everything that we created?
We created the government,
you know?
Yeah.
It's a boys only ladies,
I'm fucking with you.
I don't feel that way about the government.
I think it should have a nice balance to,
or do you think about that?
However,
the NFL is a men's football league.
All right,
men only.
I'm give,
I'm fucking with you.
I don't give a shit if they have female coaches,
but I don't believe in the NFL getting female coaches because they give a shit
about women.
The NFL basically hit maximum density with male fans and they have just been
bending over and grabbing their fucking ankles,
trying to get as many women to enjoy the fucking game so they can make even more
fucking money selling Pink Jersey.
So then they got in business with the pink lady,
right.
Okay.
They fucking,
now they've got a coach.
But when it really comes down to what they showed their true colors,
when ray rice knocked out that lady in the fucking elevator and dragged her out
like a caveman,
you know,
they don't give a fuck.
They gave him four games over that
they don't get,
they don't even pay attention.
I don't think they even fucking pay attention.
Um,
so anyway,
so there's going to be a dot.
Got How a woman fucking coach,
just the amount of disruption that that's going to cause,
you know,
used to be back in the day,
back in the day,
the fucking coach just ran right in the locker room screaming at everybody.
Say that Dick's hanging out now.
Now you know,
and he was in the moment.
He just saw that now we're gonna have to,
to wait of everybody towels.
Lorraine's coming in
straight to watch your language.
Everybody.
Uh,
Gee,
I'll tell you,
that was a heck of a thumping.
We took there in the first half and I got to tell you,
I'm,
Oh,
I'm really disappointed.
Um,
I dunno.
I give up.
Is,
is there any place we can go?
I don't understand why they think was so fucking stupid yet.
They want to be involved in everything we're doing.
You know,
with dumb,
you know,
we're going to say a bunch of dumb shit.
Why would you want to be around us?
Jesus.
I need to take breaks from hanging out with my friends.
We're fucking idiots.
I literally have to take breaks from hanging out with my friends because if I
don't,
I'm going to die a much earlier death,
you know,
then he'd come home and you get nagged.
I really didn't think I was going to be this negative this week.
I don't know.
I don't know what to fucking tell you.
Um,
speaking of ladies,
I had a really weird,
uh,
experienced the other day.
I was walking around the block Bato but elbow with my dog,
right?
And I'm walking around the block
and a Nice Neighborhood Street and I'm coming down the street and his,
this lay coming the other way and she's dressed in workout clothes,
face a little shiny,
like she's got some sweat on her face.
Like she's been out there trying to burn some calories and I was walking and
there was a tree branch that was in my way.
So I kind of had to like kind of put my head in her lane a little bit and goal
around it.
And as I did that,
she leaned in,
okay.
In,
reached down towards my balls and said,
you left nut is hanging a little lower than your right.
And I swear,
I swear to God,
and if my left,
my arms weren't swinging,
like my left arm hit her left arm reaching down,
like she was pointing.
I don't know what she was doing.
I turned around,
I looked,
at first I thought I was wearing shorts and one of my balls was one of my
shorts.
I was like,
how fucking old am I?
I looked down,
I had on sweatpants and I look back at it like,
what the fuck?
And She just kept walking.
She didn't seem crazy.
Okay.
I Dunno if she was just out there fucking with white people.
I have no idea what was going on with her.
But,
uh,
it was bizarre.
It kind of made me laugh,
but I didn't like how she tried to touch me,
that fucking really annoyed me.
She fucking leaned in to her head,
was like right next to my head and then I just realized how easily somebody
could just fucking come,
could just stab me while I was walking down the street.
Um,
that not prepared.
She totally got in within the fucking the Bruce Lee perimeter.
Right?
Dude,
that was Bruce Lee.
Like his reaction.
I mean she would have been across the fucking street,
one inch punch.
She would've been like three quarters of an inch into a fucking tree.
I just stood right there all,
whoa,
what are we,
what are you trying to say to me?
I don't know.
The fact that nothing happened,
I think it's Kinda hilarious.
Slash slash like a little unsettling.
And then like two days later I'm walking the same fucking root cause you know,
God knows I don't learn a lesson and this other lady's coming
and she just starts talking.
I know what the fuck she's saying.
I,
yeah,
dog.
I've had it.
It's walking by like nod.
Okay.
Feel like I was like in a time machine
and I just gone into the future and it was like right before everybody realized
that I wasn't from that time,
which would scare everybody and then of course they'd have to kill me,
you know,
after they examined my brain while I was still alive.
I don't know.
What I've been trying to tell you guys is I've been having a rough time here on
my walks lately.
Um,
speaking of which,
who fuck tries to grab somebody balls when they're walking by it.
You realize how fucking hilarious setters,
hey,
you left nuts hang lower than your writing,
which is like,
what the fuck?
I actually watched another 10 feet and then immediately slammed my hand down in
my pocket to be like,
did she just take my wallet?
Because that would have been brilliant because she had me,
but mentally between my fucking ears and not even paying attention to anything
on my body,
she could have fucking taken it out,
shown it to me,
put it back in there and taking everything I had.
Try that this week,
ladies.
You know,
I guarantee you 99% of guys I'm not going to,
they're going to have a same stupid store and at 99%,
a lot of people doing that UFC shit.
You know what,
ladies?
Don't do it.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
I been going really hard as far as the working out and all that shit.
And uh,
all of a sudden my left knee was a little fucking tech and I was like,
oh no,
I fucked up my knee for life.
It was just feeling like that bone on bone shit like a fuck.
Here we go.
Am I going to be that guy who can't walk hobbles out to his car?
Like a fucking former NFL running back and then I get fat.
What do I do then?
I just eat one piece of lettuce every day so I don't become a complete tub of
shit.
And um,
it just so happens I was walking down the same street,
almost the exact same place with that lady,
said my one of my balls was hanging it down a little lower than the other one.
Um,
I swear to God,
I would say she was crazy,
but she was dressed in workout clothes,
color coordinated workout gloves.
Um,
but it's not crazy,
right?
I Dunno.
So anyways,
right there,
this guy goes,
hey bill,
Bill my bank.
So I met this guy at this party and um,
he used to be fat and he lost all this weight,
you know,
he's in the process of it.
So,
you know,
I fucking love meeting people like that.
I'm asking him what he's doing.
I'm amping them up,
keep after it,
man.
You know what I'm saying?
All that shit.
And I just so happened to run into them.
You say,
I say,
how are you doing with the workouts?
He goes,
good,
he's asked me how you don't want to do.
I was and I was like,
I fucked up my name and I don't know,
I think I was skipping rope and I on concrete,
I think I fucked it up.
And he goes,
that happened to me,
man.
He goes,
it might just be the muscles in your leg or a little tightness,
sorta like,
uh,
putting pressure on it.
So I was like,
really?
So I went home and for like three days in a row,
uh,
I did this yoga thing that I got this audio clip does,
Bryan Kest.
he might be on iTunes.
It's a great,
it's like a 90 minute one of his class a classes and uh,
okay.
I did it for like half hour,
40 minutes every day.
My knee feels good as no,
so wow,
that's four.
That's for you all guys out there just in case,
uh,
you feel like you've just tweaked it a little bit.
Sometimes.
I just learned that if you stretch a little bit,
sometimes it's actually something else pulling on it,
putting your knee out of whack.
Um,
so having said that,
all freckles
who could not be beat,
it's just been crushing it.
Dude.
I've been eating so well now.
Like I don't even fucking think about chips,
cookies,
any salt,
sugar shit.
I was like,
I do not want to eat that stuff.
It's going to make me feel gross.
That's not much of a fucking twinkle toes I've been eating like,
and um,
I weighed myself this morning after I walk the dog around the block and went on
my hike.
One 71.8.
All right.
Now I know a lot of that.
The second I had a glass of water,
I probably went back up to one 73 but,
uh,
I got to get down to one 71 on Sunday and I'm right on fucking schedule
right on schedule.
So,
uh,
I'm psyched man.
I've never stuck with it for this fucking long.
Actually.
No,
I've stuck with it to like a buck 68 and then I just go like,
you know what,
I'm getting a Burger and if 12 back,
you know why?
Cause I fucking earned it,
right.
And I go out there and that's literally like you stopped smoking crack and then
you just like,
well I've been good.
I can go hit the crack pipe and then I'm going to be fine.
And then what I do,
I get that grease,
I get that salt,
I get that sugar back in me and then I start craving that shit and then I start
going up again.
I feel myself getting bigger.
I don't want to step on the scale.
I go into fucking denial.
And then one day somebody fucking calls me a fat fuck on Twitter and I step on
the scale and I'm like a buck 90.
Yeah.
In the words of Mr. White in reservoir dogs asphalt.
Right.
Y'all my shot made asshole.
Um,
so anyways,
I'm,
I'm hanging in there.
Um,
do you know what actually fucking did I actually looked up,
cause this is the time of year I start getting into baseball.
When it started to a Amanda,
you know,
um,
and I actually looked up the American league east and I knew the red sox weren't
doing well.
I thought we were in second to last place.
Do we are in dead last place
and we are seven games behind Baltimore.
Who's fucking in second to last place where 12 and a half back from the Toronto
Blue Jays who shouldn't even be in the fucking league
baseball is United States of America's game.
All right,
Tara,
I fucking Canada.
You have no business being in the league.
You know what I mean?
What do you got?
You got to fucking teams and you lost one of them.
What are you adding to the sport?
Look at,
look at the United States of America.
Look how,
look how we had the decency to flesh out your little game.
A hockey,
Huh?
It wasn't for us.
How many teams would you have?
Montreal,
Ottawa,
Toronto,
Winnipeg,
Calgary,
Edmonton,
and Vancouver.
You'd have seventeenths.
That's it.
And you know what?
You probably be happy as hell,
right?
How fucking psych would you guys be?
Ft?
Nho was just so 17th when that'd be fun.
Just like you CFL have all these fucking guys who couldn't make it in the
fucking NFL playing up there.
Well,
I guess the NHL would,
would be the NHL.
Oh,
fuck you saying.
Just kicked me off the Internet.
My Internet is the shit in one room.
In the house,
actually.
The living room,
dining room,
kitchen.
It's fucking great.
But the second I go into my office,
which is where my computer lives,
shits the bed.
God dammit.
How about the Yankees though,
man?
Huh?
The Yankees are in second place.
Good for them.
They didn't go out and try and buy the league like we did.
You know,
the Yankees are like,
uh,
they're like the fuck an older brother that now cleaned up and shit.
We're like,
the younger brother is still fucking party and you know,
y'all abroad,
I don't do that shit anymore.
You know,
I go to bed at 10 o'clock,
get up early in the morning,
drink of water with some lemon in it.
I got to respect the Yankees,
man.
They're not trying to fucking buy it.
Well God knows they still have a bunch of big contracts,
but they didn't go out and buy a bunch of expensive panda bears or whatever the
fuck we did.
What the hell was that third baseman thinking?
Why would you leave San Francisco?
Like how much money can they give you to walk away from winning a world series
every other fucking year?
You know,
he was already making zillions of dollars.
I want to make a zillion one.
And then he goes over to the red sox and now look at you.
I mean,
I always do and I know he's having a rough start,
but now lucky if fucking 12 and a half games out of first and isn't fun
whenever fucking money you're making more in Boston when you made even more.
If you want another fucking world series just doing commercials.
Hey,
this is the panda fucking talking about us.
San Francisco,
dry cleaning.
Come on down to Alcatraz and just do a bunch of shit.
You know,
come on down to the fucking wharf.
A best gay club in the China fucking district.
The Presidio.
You could do all those.
All the fucking
San Francisco Zone aftershave lotion.
You could just do that.
The whole fucking winner and whatever extra money the red sox were going to give
you.
Right?
You can make it up locally.
Then head north,
you know,
go up to the wine country,
get shit faced with a couple of third base groupies.
I don't know what it is.
I just always liked that petition.
Right.
Did you go out to Boston with all the humidity?
I will say at least they have water out there.
They have lakes and shit.
Okay.
Lush land.
Maybe you made a good move.
So as the apocalypse go,
I agree with it,
but as far as a baseball movie,
I think it was really stupid.
I'll do your bill.
Do you?
They're never played in a fucking pro league in your life.
All right,
here we go.
Uh,
do a little advertising.
Once again,
people come on up over the top of the hour,
another Thursday afternoon.
Fucking Tesa.
If you're just walking by your husband's computer and he's listening,
I'm going to add,
I'm going to have the audio from the,
the last phone thing.
It's completely ridiculous.
Steven fucking try to teach something on a podcast.
People listened to it from beginning to end,
don't they?
Or they just fast forward to the part that they want.
All right.
Zip recruiter business owners.
Did you know that summer is a great time to hire the best people?
Yeah.
Why is that?
With your competitors on vacation,
there's less competition for quality candidates.
Does that make any sense?
What?
Who's on vacation?
Dunkin donuts just shuts down.
But posting your job in one place isn't enough to find them.
And when you're short staffed,
there's no time to deal with dozens of different jobs sites until now.
Here we go.
Now we're getting into the meats and potato radio,
the meat and potatoes fucking taters.
Uh,
thanks to ziprecruiter.com you can post to 100 plus job sites with a single
click just post once and within 24 hours,
watch your candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface plus be instantly matched to candidates from over 4
million resumes.
Ziprecruiter has been used by over 400,000 businesses and you could try it right
now for free.
Jesus Christ.
What more do you want from these people?
Try Zip recruiter and get your perfect candidate this summer before they go to
somebody else today.
You can try zip recruiter for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/burr.
That's ziprecruiter.com/burr zip recruiter.com/burr.
Um,
lastly,
but certainly not least,
Lee,
if you would like to,
uh,
contribute to the,
to the Monday morning podcasters,
the afternoon podcasts,
uh,
but you don't want to give me any fucking money.
Next time you go on Amazon to buy something,
maybe getting yourself a fucking Paris slippers.
Do I got some slip
as,
oh my God,
I'm just swing by a billboard.com.
Click on the podcast page,
then click on the Amazon link.
It'll just take you there.
It doesn't cost you any extra money.
They give me credit for fucking drive and traffic there.
They break me off a little bit.
I take 10% of that and send it to Saint Jude's.
Speaking of which I owe those fuckers some money.
Um,
so anyways,
what was I going to talk?
What the fuck is he going to talk?
Oh,
I know what I'm going to talk about.
You know,
every once in a while I always make fun of the yet that album,
never mind from Nirvana.
I don't even make fun of the album cause it's a fucking killer album.
But I just make fun of how everybody pretends like they knew.
You know what I mean?
I knew the second I heard that album,
I realize that rock music,
as we knew it had now changed forever and that,
that fucking uh,
Kurt Cobain documentary,
his mother,
his mother was going,
oh,
I was just like,
you better get ready because this album is going to change your life.
Everybody fucking set gave fuck everybody know this is what kills me as much as
they rubbed the balls of that album a year earlier.
Jane's addiction put out that ritual,
ritual de la habitual,
however the fuck you say it.
Okay,
call me crazy.
But that album absolutely fucking smokes.
Nevermind.
Am I out of my mind and I'm not trying to cause a war.
He ever,
teen Nevada had fucking Jane's addiction fans.
All you 40 something year olds like me with your fucking worn out affliction tee
shirts.
I'm not trying to cause a war here,
but am I outta my fucking mind?
The fact that they put that album out when,
when the shit that was was,
I mean that was,
that was really the height,
the height of like somewhere,
once,
once when kip wingers band came out and she's only 17 was a hit and he was
wearing like that Pastel fucking a tank top.
Maybe it wasn't pastel.
I don't know what,
I know he had a beard like me and he had much better hair.
So why am I shitting on him?
I'm just saying the shit that was out,
the fact that they put that thing out.
And then Perry Farrell,
his lyrics,
his phrasing,
this shit didn't even rhyme.
One of my brothers absolutely loved that song.
Uh,
of course,
which I hated at first thought it sounded like a bunch of Gypsy horseshit and
then it really listened to the lyrics and I really just got into it and it was
bought your big brother holding your hands and making you slap your own face.
And he equated it to how,
uh,
nature,
how one animal's got to eat the other animal while it's admiring the beauty of
the way it runs away.
All this deep fucking,
is there anything on fucking
a mosquito?
My luck paid.
Oh,
oh,
well.
Whatever.
Nevermind.
I Dunno.
It's like he took some seventh grade girl's diary.
Any fucking wrote it up.
Oh,
I'm going to get shit for this one.
Um,
I just think that al I and also,
um,
obviously I'm a huge fucking nirvana fan.
All right.
Um,
I'm just,
I'm just saying,
let's give credit where credit is due and the drumming,
Stephen Perkins,
drumming on that fucking album.
I don't even know where to begin
with the drum parts that,
that guy came up with.
They just did diff to fucking work of art from the beginning to the end.
My two favorite drum albums,
um,
of that period from about 87 to 1990,
I love Stephen Adler's playing on appetite for destruction.
Just how you could pull out all the guitar,
all the base,
all the vocals and all that.
And even like,
uh,
basically somebody with very little musical background could listen to just the
drum tracks and know what song he was playing too.
And that,
to me,
that's always such a killer.
Um,
that to me,
that's always such a killer sign of an unbelievable drummer because you can
basically play like the same little rock music.
I mean,
you can play like four fucking pizza and get through a whole goddamn album.
You know what I mean?
Which is also another art.
But like the guitar player,
I can't play the same fucking chords and play the same chords,
but he's got to switch it up,
is basically what I'm saying.
He's got to write a new song,
you know what I mean?
So this guys like John Bonham,
Steven Adler,
these guys,
they come up with specific drum parts to fit the songs.
I just think that it's on a whole other level.
And if you listen to the drumming,
um,
like then she did that stuff on the ride cymbal.
And then how about any gets his high hat coming in and,
uh,
like he comes off the ride,
I think with his right hand hits the snare while he opens the high hat,
hitting it with his left hand.
That shit,
I think he does that as he gets into like the,
the verse.
It's fucking incredible.
Um,
and I think even his drum and right through porno for Pyros when he got rid of
all his toms,
he and he had like those bongos and shit though that band fucking blew me away.
Nobody thought they were weird and shit.
I fucking love them.
Do you mind when they did that?
Uh,
first time I saw them cause I was so fucking like they made that album and then
they immediately broke up and I was fucking devastated because I was just like,
these guys are the guys,
this is it.
What are they going to do next?
And then they fucking break up and I'm,
then Paris started that porno for Pyros,
if I remember correctly,
he got that name watching the La Riots on TV,
everything burn out,
burn it down.
He was like,
this is porno for Pyros,
this is like porno for pyros wherever.
And then that was the name of the band.
And the first time I saw them was on the Larry Sanders show where that was like
a show within a show and they were the actual musical guests.
And um,
they came out and sang that song.
They had that killer fucking baseline.
Perry was on the fucking harmonica.
And then,
uh,
you know,
Steven Parkwoods is playing this drum kit like I'd never seen before.
Uh,
all I'm saying like book,
they look,
they're both fucking great albums,
but I would,
uh,
I dunno,
I'd have to give the,
I guess Nirvana's because it was more popular I guess,
and sold more,
did have more of a cultural effect bought.
Um,
I dunno do it that,
that fucking,
that ritual album is a,
is a fucking monster.
I actually [inaudible] I was sick.
That album is,
I actually learned how to meditate on the second half,
the second side of that album when I was still living at home with my parents 25
fucking years ago.
I used to put on the second side of that album,
which started off with three days and then it went into a,
then she did,
I think it was the name of it.
And then of course,
and then classic girl.
And,
uh,
I would just start meditating and,
um,
I used to be so good at it to get that feeling where you feel like you leave in
your body and like,
like I would shut down everything and just concentrate on just paying attention
to them.
When I was,
I was breathing my,
my diet,
my stomach basically going up and down and you'd focus totally on that and I
would be almost like looking down at it with my eyes shut.
And then once I got to one point,
then I would just sort of look up with my eyes closed or straight ahead and then
I would just feel like I was floating and um,
okay.
And it would always happen like right around this particular part in that song,
right where he says true hunting's over.
I would start floating
and uh,
it was fucking amazing.
I would just feel like I was floating as an asset that the apex of that song was
building,
building was just whatever that Jesus,
Dannon and uh,
all the way to the end.
And then,
then she did came and really mellow.
And then I'm just going to be,
I'd go all the way through classic girl.
And then in the end you think it's the end of the album.
And then there's like this little pause and then you hear Perry Farrell standing
and of course is weird phrasing.
He just goes like,
good night,
good night.
This is really weird fucking way.
And that would be it.
I would just fucking pass out.
I did it every fucking night.
And um,
and then I lost the ability to do it because as I was starting to float,
rather than just experiencing it,
I would start,
I was like,
oh good,
oh good.
It's happening.
And then I would get in my head and then I couldn't do it and then I'd get
frustrated and uh,
I just fucking gave up on it.
But,
so if anybody has any suggestions on how to fucking get back into it,
because I tried it again.
I bought some Jane's Addiction,
um,
albums,
some bootleg live album,
not bootleg.
I mean I bought them at Amoeba,
but,
um,
I don't know.
There's just something about that second side,
like the,
the,
the guitar effects that Dave Navarro used and everything was just an amazing
fucking album.
And,
uh,
you know,
I don't think I could do that with a nirvana album and to have an album that you
could actually fucking meditate too,
and it also fucking,
you know,
it's still rocks to,
I don't know at this.
I think it's fucking killer.
I'm just going on and on forever here.
So when you're talking about an album for 25 fucking years ago,
so anyways,
um,
it's 33 minutes past the hour,
uh,
the phone store,
Girl's story,
I left Yang and
um,
I got,
uh,
I got all the audio and I'm going to play it here and then we're going to do
some classic Monday morning podcast stuff.
I hope you guys have a great rest of the week.
If you try and lose weight,
stick with it.
You know,
if you fuck up,
just get after it the next day.
You know that you're in control.
And,
uh,
you know,
if you've never listened to that ritual album,
I'm telling you,
just,
just fucking,
just put it on this block out a nice fucking hour,
your life and just,
you know,
at night when you got nobody calling,
you shut off your phone and just pull it out.
Turn off the fucking lights.
Light a candle,
you know,
have a drink,
smoked some weed or something.
Put that fucking album on dude.
I'm telling you.
Telling you.
Um,
all right,
well maybe I'll do it if you want to.
I don't,
I don't fucking tell you what you want it wouldn't,
you know who am I right?
You know Josh just got doing a podcast.
All right,
here we go.
Here's the phone,
phone store.
A girl.
I can't even read.
Phone store girl story that got cut off on the Monday morning podcast.
You guys have a great weekend.
You can't.
Um,
all right.
Phone store girl.
All right,
Billy boy.
Last week my girlfriend lent her cell phone.
Oh,
what to you
last week my girl lent her cell phone because mine,
Shit,
the bed.
You,
you missed a word there.
Lent me her cell phone.
Okay.
I borrowed a phone on the way to get,
oh,
Jesus.
Oh God.
Here we go.
I borrowed her phone and the way to get my new phone because I had some work
calls to make as they left the house.
I thought it was strange because it felt like,
because I,
it felt like we would be breaking up soon.
I get to the place and a young cute chick is working there.
I ended up getting paired with her over the other miserable looking losers
working there.
Why?
I thought this has got to go another direction.
I thought I'm going to say you went there and then she got some fucked up text.
All right.
Here we go.
At one point I had to hand her my girlfriend's phone because I had taken a
picture of a number.
I needed to activate my new phone.
When the girl slid the pics slid the picture over by accident.
Yup.
You it a picture of my girlfriend topless.
The girls swipe back immediately and I just stood there.
I actually didn't even really react much,
just kind of took it all in.
She looked at me and goes,
good for you.
Oh Jesus.
This girl's a Gamer that broke the ice.
This girl was very cool.
Yeah.
You think we joked around before and after the end,
after this incident.
All right,
this is what you need to do.
Break up with this other girl immediately.
Cause you already said you feel like you're going to break up and you don't seem
upset by which means you don't like this girl,
you know,
lover I should say.
Or maybe you love her,
but not that way.
Dumper and get with this girl.
All right,
let's see where this fucking goes.
And Paul back your heart though for a minute.
This girl might be a fucking killer toe.
She might be a,
uh,
a stud on the other side of the fence and she's going to fucking break your
heart.
So just a,
okay,
see where it goes.
I'm already saying that before I get to the end of this.
Anyways,
he goes,
I get in the car and I realized I haven't seen the picture of my girlfriend.
She never sent it to me pre.
Perhaps she didn't like it or perhaps it was for someone else.
Yeah.
What the fuck just happened?
Wait a minute.
You guessed it.
A picture of my girlfriend topless.
The girls swiped back immediately and I just stood there and took it all in.
She said good for you.
That broke the ice.
We kind of joked around before and after the citizens.
I get in the car and I realized I haven't seen the picture of my girlfriend.
She never sent it to me.
Oh cause it was on her phone.
Oh wait.
She sent it to somebody else?
Yeah.
Dude,
this is like a great movie for half.
She didn't like it or perhaps it was for someone else.
I think it was the latter.
Of course it was because it was a good picture.
If that is in question,
we can always refer to the phone store girls' reaction,
which was pretty positive also.
I sense this was happening anyways with this dude.
She knows,
but that's a whole other story,
Dude.
Get the fuck out of that relationship and get with the phone girl.
Yeah.
She seems like a happy,
open,
free spirit.
Uh,
as it would happen.
I have to go back to the store because the girl gave me the wrong charger at
this didn't seem odd at first until I thought about how the iPhone section in
the Samsung section on different sides of the store.
She walked over to the wrong side and grabbed it.
I'm going back in a couple of days.
Mig,
I may just tell the phone girl the whole story.
I realized that this was how my girlfriend was cheating on me or at least
sending photos.
Thank you for the contribution to helping me know the truth.
Thoughts.
Should I tell the story in a very casual way?
I'm pretty sure I can pull it off.
Why would you fucking bring up that shit?
You should break up with the other girl.
Yeah,
and just fucking ask the phone girl out.
Save yourself all of that bullshit and just cut to this chase.
That woman at the,
at the phone store
was looking at it like,
good for you man.
Like you getting some ass.
That's how she said it.
She doesn't like it.
That's your girlfriend or whatever,
you know,
break up with your girlfriend and get with this girl.
The other one,
uh,
you know,
she's fucking cheating on you,
dude.
If I had to guess,
would you say,
oh yeah,
that's right.
I took a topless photo and I forgot to send it to you and deleted.
Oh,
Jesus.
Yeah.
That's what I would do.
I mean,
look,
okay.
I don't know,
like what the vibe was when you talked to him.
Maybe you feel you have to tell the story,
but my gut says don't do that.
Break up with her and don't tell the fucking story to the phone chick and have
yourself a wonderful rest of the summer because that sounds like something what
fucking guy wouldn't want to pull.
Who wouldn't want to be with a woman like that?
Good for you,
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking chip.
Um,
anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
Um,
please get the word out about my MSG show.
If you could.
Madison Square Garden for those of you who,
uh,
I dunno who walked into the room later.
Um,
sometimes I feel like this is radio.
Then I'm like,
no,
he isn't radio.
They listen to the whole fucking thing bill.
Um,
yeah.
Cause obviously I've got to sell a ton of tickets and um,
yeah,
I don't want to be standing on stage alone that night.
But uh,
once again,
seriously guys,
thank you for everybody.
All the years
you guys have been coming out to my shows and uh,
you know,
and the repeat customers,
which always makes me,
you know,
write new jokes on a regular basis,
which is fucking awesome.
So,
uh,
which gets me more fans and it all feeds at the ones on TV to the others.
I don't say that.
Alright,
that's a podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves up.
Check in on you on Thursday.
All right.
See,
I was one of those times was just like,
you know what,
there's not enough light thing in the world.
No.
Just as far as the odds of being struck by lightning.
We need to bring that average up because the amount of fucking morons out there
versus actually intelligent people,
you got to hit a fucking moron,
you know basically going to hit a moron or are you going to hit the ocean?
Does,
is it going to be the top two in that order?
Yeah.
Even all the fucking world is three quarters fucking water.
You still got a higher chance as lightning to fucking hit a moron.
That's that.
That's,
I'm telling you.
That's my goddamn theory and that's what I want the new staff to be.
Okay.
Rather than being like,
you know,
the odds of getting hit by lightning or higher of blah,
blah,
blah.
I want it to turn into,
I want so much lightening that,
that,
that the new stat is the odds of an intelligent person actually being hit by
lightening are x,
y,
and Z.
Do you like how in my own little style and that squirrels that I'm actually
intelligent and everybody else is just a sea of morons?
Huh?
You don't have thoughts like that.
Murderous thoughts.
I was actually talking to this broad up in San Francisco and um,
yeah,
I got this whole chunk about hitting women that I've been doing on stage and uh,
it's actually something embarrassing I have to admit about myself as much as I
do the,
the comedy thing for a living.
I'm really bad at picking up on sarcasm.
I don't know why I use sarcasm.
I'm sarcastic,
right?
But for some reason when someone uses it against me,
I,
I've just like that old guy downstairs.
But if I told you that shit last year when I was dragging my Christmas tree down
the stairs and he stuck his head out the window and he just goes,
beautiful morning,
isn't it?
And he had this fucked up look on his face,
but he said,
beautiful morning,
isn't it?
So I was confused and I just went,
yeah,
it is a beautiful morning.
And I'm thinking,
why is he yelling with that,
twist it up,
look in his face.
And then I walked around the corner.
It's like,
oh,
he didn't mean it.
What he really meant was she making a lot of fucking noise ruining this
beautiful morning.
So he got me.
Then I always end up feeling stupid,
so you know,
I'm doing this whole chunk on hitting the broads over there and I'm standing
afterwards whoring myself out,
right.
Sell on my DVD,
showed a little bit of leg doing what I gotta do.
This fucking woman is walking out in,
her husband has sort of shuffling her out and she starts going,
uh
oh she has,
she,
she has is once again the twist it up,
look on her face.
She goes,
thanks for the domestic violence jokes.
I really appreciated it.
I really appreciated the domestic violence.
Jux thanks a lot for the domestic violence jokes.
That's what she was doing.
And because she was saying thanks,
it just,
it went totally past my head.
I was more just confused by her facial expression.
So she said,
yeah,
I really appreciate it.
Thanks a lot.
I'm literally just waving gone.
Alright,
glad you enjoyed the show.
Which is funny because it probably pissed her off more,
but I was sincerely thanking her completely missing her sarcasm.
What she was really saying was ivy that dealt with that personally or that's
happening to somebody right now or has happened to someone or it grew up with it
or whatever,
and you brought up bad memories and you ruined my fucking evening.
That's what she was really sorry.
But of course I took it at face value,
which actually when I look back on it,
I think makes it even funnier because who's Kevin who she already thinks I'm a
fucking moron at that point,
you know?
So it would actually would have made her a little bit happier if I tried to
appear intelligent.
It's like actually a,
you missed the point of the geocode.
It was really trying to do is expose the hypocrisy of us,
some of the relationships between the male and female sex.
If I went that route,
you know,
then she could have gotten this hot.
But the fact that I literally was the moron that she thought I was,
and then yeah,
there was this whole line of people,
you don't want to just realize I should be struck by lightening.
What the fuck is wrong with me?
I'm one of those fucking morons.
So
conversation
basis.
All right,
question bill.
Being a frequent flyer.
Don't you think this controversy over the new body scanners is fucking bullshit?
A guy hit a bomb in his fucking underwear.
What exactly do these complaining bastards expect us to scale back on security?
We have become so pampered and use to the utmost comfort that we are doing the
terrorist's job for them.
Who gives a fuck if someone is seeing your cock or your tits?
He or she is seeing hundreds a day.
Uh,
you sir,
are a fucking moron.
All right?
If you go through airport security,
I don't know if you've noticed.
They're not exactly the fucking navy seals,
although they have gotten better in the last couple of years,
but they don't,
you know,
they're always shooting the shit.
They're always fucking around.
They're not really paying attention.
It doesn't really look like it's a high paying fucking job.
All right,
let's go with that.
let's go with secondly,
uh,
a body scanner,
entire body scale.
Let's get over the fact that you don't want a naked picture of yourself,
which is,
you're fucking right to not want that,
by the way.
All right?
Secondly,
I don't know about you,
but I fly every other weekend and when I go on benders like this at the end of
the year,
cause I owe the bank,
are concerned,
the fucking government,
a bunch of money.
I go on like,
you know,
four or five weeks in a row,
I fly.
All right?
So I got to get up full bond,
body scan,
uh,
on the way out and the way back.
You know,
I really have to start checking to see that I'm not going to be completely
filled up with memory on this fucking Olympus ls 10.
They have the God damn time right there.
I apologize.
Let me get back to what the fuck I was talking about.
Um,
yeah,
so,
so you're basically saying that I shouldn't complain that like six weeks in a
fucking row and a total of 12 times I'm going to take radiation from head to
fucking toe.
All right?
And don't even tell me,
oh,
it's only for fucking second to when you go to get your fucking,
you know,
teeth x-rayed.
They put that leather fucking,
that led vest leather,
that led vest over all your fucking Oregon's.
And then they go lay leave the fucking room.
And I'm supposed to stand there.
Like I met a Jay z concert and I'm getting frisk at the same time with my
fucking legs spread and doing that Jay z thing over my head.
And they're going to know,
fuck that this cancer in my family.
I'm not doing it.
Pat me down.
So that's why I did the one on the,
on the way out.
I was like,
yeah,
I'm not doing that thing.
And I said to pat me down.
So then you know,
they did it and they said they came up to me and this guy said,
I have to pat you down.
Uh,
are there any parts of your body that are,
that are,
that are sensitive?
And I wanted to be like,
well,
I'm think all of us have areas of our bodies that are sensitive
just to creep them out.
That was basically like,
no,
God grabbed my balls.
I don't give a fuck.
Right.
I didn't know what he was going to do.
So he's puts on his dishwashing gloves and starts patting me down and they don't
grab your balls.
What they do is they go way up your inner thigh and he gives you your ball bag.
A little bit of a backhand on each side of the ball bag,
you know?
So,
and I got to admit,
it made me laugh a little bit.
Yeah.
I don't give a fuck.
Yeah,
go fuck yourself.
Yeah.
You're not taking a fucking head to toe naked fucking picture of me as you,
you know you're not,
you're not fucking radiate in my entire body,
so I can get on a fucking puddle jumper to go to Hartford.
I'm not doing that.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Jesus Christ,
lazy motherfuckers.
You know
what,
what people forget.
I just don't,
I don't get it.
You know what I mean?
This is this,
I understand that they're,
you know,
quote unquote trying to keep me safe.
But what I don't understand is that people don't understand that during those
times of fear,
and let's try to keep you safe.
The amount of fucking like privileged that you lose and you never fucking get it
back.
And they always take a little more than they should.
That's why it's great that people bitch.
And it's great that you can bitch because if you bitched like this in China,
they'd probably put you to death and then harvest.
You're fucking Oregon's.
All right.
So yeah,
I think it's fine with the amount of fucking cancer that's out there and that
people fucking talk on their cell phones all the God damn time.
You don't want to end it.
You know,
you don't want to add to it with a head to toe fucking Zappa,
fucking radiation.
You know,
I'm standing there,
I don't have my fucking shoes on.
I'm stripped down to a fucking tee shirt.
I got jeans on and Shit.
I don't have anything on me,
you know?
And there's all this fucking flipping out about the fucking airplanes.
What about trains?
You could literally have a box that said,
I have dynamite on the side of it.
And you could see the fucking conductor would help you carry it on.
There's no metal detectors.
There's no nothing.
Despite the fact that 15 years ago,
that guy got on the long island railroad railroad and shut the shut the whole
fucking thing up.
So I don't like that.
I don't like that whole fucking ice skate scan my retina shit.
No,
go fuck yourself.
I'm not doing that.
And um,
it's,
you're right dude,
if you have no problem with it,
you know,
good luck with your testicular slash brain slash tongue slash throat slash big
toe cancer if you fly all the fucking time.
Like a lot of people,
I'm not doing that shit.
I'm not fucking doing that.
That's a,
they have fucked dead,
you know,
and you're acting like before this shit went down,
they haven't been keeping us safe.
You know,
they have been says nine 11.
Knock on wood,
nothing has fucking happened before.
Those stupid body scan is nothing has fucking happened.
All right,
we're fine.
Everything is fucking fine.
You don't need those goddamn things.
You know what's funny is if next week somebody actually does something that
conspiracy theorists are going to say that the government did it because people
were refusing those body scanners.
All right?
That's just my opinion,
man.
I seriously,
you know,
I'm not trying to get head to toe radiation.
I get that they're trying to fucking keep me safe,
but you know,
if they truly wanted to keep me fucking safe,
they wouldn't be shooting the shit and joking the amount of fucking times that
they are when I'm going through.
All right,
and that happens a lot.
Specifically,
it's the person who's looking at the TV screen is talking about whatever and his
joking and laughing,
which you're going to do because they have an unbelievably boring fucking job.
I would be doing the same goddamn thing,
but if they truly gave a fuck,
they would spend a lot more money on the people that they get to do the security
rather than these new fangled fucking
God damn machines.
I'm not going through those.
Pat me Down,
give,
give my fucking my ball bag.
A couple of backhands with the dishwashing gloves.
I don't give a fuck,
but I'm not going to stand there.
Spread Eagle and end up with cancer or the taint.
All right.
But you know,
you guys want to do it.
Go ahead and do,
I don't give a fuck,
but I hope enough of you say no so it doesn't become mandatory.
All right.
Hey Bill,
I just finished watching last night,
Saturday night live with Paul Mccartney and I think it's time for Paul to hang
it up for good.
I feel like a bit of an asshole for thinking it because we're all supposed to be
in awe of him because he's a Beta.
Uh,
they let them do four songs last night because everyone is in awe of him and
that's the problem.
No one wants to tell the 68 year old man with the dyed brown hair and saggy man
boobs that he doesn't have the voice for a live performance anymore.
I fear getting old and being irrelevant too.
But I hope that when it's my time to retire,
I can accept that I'm not what I once was and move on to something else that
better suits that stage of my life.
Paul should look to someone like Bano.
Not that I'm a big Bono Fan,
but I think he's done it right by imitating Bob Geldof's example of rock and
roll for philanthropy.
How about a pat on the back for getting through that sentence without fucking it
up.
Uh,
you two won't dress stadium sized crowds forever.
So Bonno set,
set himself up as a jet setting friend of the world's poor.
Even if he never gave another concert of sung another note,
he'd still have a meaningful,
he'll still have meaningful work beyond his music.
Uh,
it's like you were saying in previous podcasts,
it's good to have a side business in case show business doesn't work out best
regards.
Um,
yeah.
I kind of see what you say and a little bit,
but,
uh,
I know a lot of people saw Paul Mccartney last year on tour and said he was
fucking unbelievable.
And then I also think that the Beatles right now are a victim of a backlash
because of something that they didn't create.
I think apple,
not apple,
is that,
uh,
whatever iTunes.
That's right.
Itunes.
I got real confused there because they had apple records and then Macintosh has
a fucking apple and that's all it takes to really just send me flying down the
fucking sidelines.
Like that.
Dreadlocked son of a bitch.
You got tripped anyways.
Um,
I think iTunes has been trying to get the Beatles catalog.
Obviously it's probably the first band you would want to start with as far as if
you wanted to make money.
They finally got,
and they are from the baby boom generation,
Steve jobs and all those guys.
So this is,
you know,
this is there Jesus.
So they present the band as their Jesus and just eventually it's just inevitable
that it's going to,
uh,
annoy the generations after.
And not to mention,
because we weren't born when they were putting out albums,
it's impossible for us to see how far ahead of their fucking time they were,
you know?
And that's something I also see in comedy where I've actually gotten emails from
people going,
what's the big deal with Richard Pryor?
You know,
35 years of people ripping off his shit.
They've actually made
some of his stuff,
you know,
like after 35 years,
people finally caught up with them,
you know,
so it was,
the Beatles was so fucking far ahead of everybody,
but now it's,
it's 40,
almost 50 fucking years later.
Yeah.
Now you're going to look back on it and have to,
everybody's ripped him off.
It can be like,
dude,
what the fuck was the big deal?
All right,
so there's that.
And then the last thing is I'm sick of people throwing old people out in the
fucking yard.
You know,
like they're your old iPod speakers.
Eh,
there's a loose wire.
Fuck him.
He's out the God damn door.
I think it's bullshit.
All right.
I like old people.
Even that fucking asshole downstairs.
I like them.
I respect them.
And,
uh,
you,
what it is,
is you look at them and you see that died here and you see their saggy man boobs
right here,
wrinkled up tushies.
Right?
So you equate that with their level of intelligence rather than this fucking guy
has walked this planet for 65,
75,
85 fucking years.
And uh,
you know,
what's that expression?
Bunch of things change.
They stay the same stitch in time,
saves nine,
whatever the fucking hammer,
remember expressions,
whatever.
You know,
this guy has seen everything that you're about ready to see.
He's already seen it,
okay?
He didn't have a fucking iPod.
Who gives a fuck?
All right?
A cunt is still a cunt.
Some things don't fucking change.
And this guy has this whole wealth of knowledge that here's a guy who's been
playing live gigs for 50 something fucking years,
all right?
He can still physically play.
Why wouldn't you want to go see him?
You know,
with all his fucking experience,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean,
I could see if he was jumping off the piano,
trying to do splits and touch his fucking toes.
And then he came down and blew out his knee and they had to give him fucking a
Geritol rub right on is blown out neat then.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
But like I don't like that whole fucking,
it's like a corporate mentality.
I your skin's wrinkled up.
We have no,
you,
we don't like looking at you beat.
I Dunno,
I'd still go pay to see the rolling stones.
I would.
Why wouldn't you?
Why the fuck would those guys,
those guys give me hope that I could sit there and drag my ass out on a fucking
stage.
80 years old.
What's up with Medicaid,
you know,
out on a cruise ship.
But I do understand what you're saying because I definitely want to,
uh,
if I'm on stage
in my sixties,
in 70s,
sixties is fine cause I'm still going to be fucking annoyed and want to be out
there.
But in my seventies,
if I'm still on fucking stage,
I want it to be because uh,
because I'm not because I need the money because I want to be out there.
All right.
I remember Keith Richard's saying like,
someone was like,
when are you guys gonna hang it up?
He's like,
never.
Yeah,
I'm a musician.
This is what I do.
I will do this in front of two people or 200,000.
It's what the fuck I do.
You want me to put down my guitar?
Okay.
You know,
he has a great line in his book where he talks about how much he loves guitar.
I don't know if I said this last week at Keith just has this book called life.
It's the fucking shit.
And um,
he talks about how he loves guitar.
So much debt to this day.
Like he opens a guitar case and just the smell of a guitar,
he wants to crawl in there and close the lid.
All right?
So if you ask this guy to stop going up playing live,
you might as well put a bullet in his brain.
You're killing them in.
Okay.
So having said that,
let Paul Mccartney do is fucking thing.
Has any been through enough?
I mean,
that guy truly found the love of his life.
All right,
you fucking dies then.
He,
he's in a bad place,
like the fucking jets strength coach.
He goes out,
he married some gold digging whore with one leg,
you know,
which was the classic fucking Miss Direction.
Cause I bet in the back of his head he kept going,
you know,
I think she's a fucking gold digger.
And then that other place,
it's like,
dude,
she only has one leg man stuff,
so me.
Right.
And then he just
gave into that.